[Music]
welcome to nuke gaming Network for the
first global event I was horrific ly
unprepared I guess I just really didn't
know what to expect and I certainly
didn't look into it too much before it
was released the result I got bugger all
in the way of classified gear in an
attempt to avoid this situation in the
next global event arriving 3rd of
October I've thrown together the super
quick video to sum up and remind us of
what we currently know about it and what
we can do to prepare now if you go into
your dossier and check out the
commendation page under GE assault you
can get a pretty good idea of what to
expect a large number of the
commendations talk about increased
close-range damage or specific close
range weapons like agent with a shotgun
here you meet to kill three enemies
within 5 seconds using a shotgun on will
tier 5 on heart or above during the
assault this global event will be
focusing on close quarters combat which
makes sense as the last one is all about
range so in order to take full advantage
of all of the global event bonuses
you'll need to be prepared to get up
close and personal but there's not just
the bonus damage we need to think about
in the first global event bonus damage
was given to range but also getting too
close to the NPC's heads up doing
considerably more damage to us so if
this is anything to go by if we're
getting bonus close combat damage then
we're likely to take more damage when it
range from the enemy if they make sense
I spent a while constructing this chart
that might help further explain what I'm
trying to say basically close to the
enemy good far from the enemy bad I
think this will be considerably more
difficult than the first global event
and strategy is going to be more
important through the commendations we
can see what missions an incursion will
be featured during the event for example
looking at job done we can see that the
featured missions will be queens
tunneled Russian Consulate General
Assembly Grand Central Station and
Falcons lost will be the incursion so in
order for you to get you and your team
ready for this new close combat modifier
you can start getting experience in each
of these missions and practicing new
strategies before the event starts the
weapon types that you want to use SMGs
and shotguns high damage close combat
weapons in order to be fully organized
I'd also have a build or two prepared
that could take full advantage of these
weapon types sits like alpha bridge
lines
or sentries call would be good there
also seems to be a lot of commendations
around completing activities without
using medical skills I'm not sure of the
impact of these or if it's simply just
for those specific activities but it
might be worth looking to add some
health on kill to your builds too I'll
be trying out my new DPS tank build
which is a tanky SMG build utilizing the
ballistic shield and the d3 FNC set with
25% health on kill and a big fat
defensive shield I think it should work
quite nicely in this global of it if
you're interested in taking in a nosy
I'll leave a link in the description so
that's about all we've got on the next
global event good luck and when it
starts just keep farming those GE
credits we all know how difficult it is
to get that classified gear outside of
these events you definitely want to pull
a few extra hours hopefully this was
useful to some of you and you'll be a
little more prepared for the upcoming
global event if it helped give you a
little bit more understanding of what to
expect please leave a like and subscribe
for future content thanks
[Music]